the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I'm Sanjoy Mahajan this course is
teaching college-level science and
engineering the course is intended for
graduate students sometimes some towards
the end of their PhD who are intending
to go on to academic teaching careers
but all graduate students are welcome
and even undergraduates who have a
strong interest in teaching the goal of
the course is to give some preparation
and background into the principles of
teaching so graduate students in fact as
undergraduates to all get the same for
their specific research area for example
in physics to learn the principles of
conservation of momentum and energy but
in teaching everyone is basically just
thrown to the wolves and figured well if
you know your subject you can teach or
and given very little preparation so the
idea is to actually show that teaching
and thinking about teaching is very
serious intellectual activity and
there's general ideas and principles
that can be used to make teaching much
more successful and therefore students
learn much more and enjoy what they're
learning but many departments encourage
their students who they know we're going
on to teaching careers they say well you
might actually find this course
interesting it's paired also with
another new program at MIT called the
TTA certificate program which is a
non-credit option where students do
about 6 or 7 seminars over an hour and a
half each and do our work for each
seminar here this is the sort of for
credit cousin of that course
and for students who want to do
everything in one semester and want
something on their transcript as well so
at the end of each lecture I give out a
short sheet that has three questions on
it one is what was most confusing today
or what do you wonder about most what
example or teaching technique worked
well or not well and any other comments
and so at the end of each session the
students have one or two minutes to fill
that out and at the end of the next
session I answered all the questions
though I've just amazed at the fawful
miss the questions and how right on they
were and how many useful suggestions I
got for when I teach the class the next
time many students have told me that
they think everyone who teaches should
take it and some told me also that they
wish some of their professors had taken
those classes the professors from there
when they were undergraduates but on the
other hand if it were required then it
wouldn't be such a lively atmosphere as
it is now where we have students who
really are fascinated by teaching and
are therefore much more motivated to
contribute but the thing the theme that
I got from many many students was wow
this has really helped them thinking
about their teaching and set out finally
this may be the only preparation I get
in teaching and I'm really glad I had
that